I don't really understand borderline
like the word borderline bordering on
what mmm exactly my point on crazy we
turn a thing yeah and even emotional
steve-o good day
so tell me lights up emotional stable
yeah I leave one extreme emotion to hit
another and I'm like okay just need a
break oh no oh now we're another one oh
right wasn't ready for any of this and
then my friends and then there's the
extreme anger that I bought or aren't
cuz I don't want to be in any luck woman
I'm gonna talk about label so I bottle
it up but should someone lift the lid on
my anger
so help them to me it's mostly very
extreme very intense emotions whereas a
normal person goes from sort of the four
to six throughout the day there's no
normal mood it's like between a 4 and a
6 on our normal day is we're at 307 Wow
but on an extreme day we'll go between
the 10 and a 1 but if you're used to
living life between a 4 and 6 you can't
comprehend feeling oh yeah you know I
mean
I can't even process building a romantic
with a con its energy because building
trust and yeah that intense fear of
abandonment like I'm very much ready for
you to leave now
like not even and I'm just like go away
oh yeah I'm way to be trash and the
whole I want you but I'm gonna push you
as far away as possible because I'm so
scared that if I get close to you're
gonna leave and I'm gonna be feeling
that one again and I don't want to be
there but I think I do have I do have
faith and I do believe that the right
person somebody that's understanding
enough and compassionate enough to
accept that you know these things on I'm
not doing these things on purpose this
is a reaction to trauma you know and
this is a lot of people aren't gonna be
yeah take to build these relationships
house years of work and whatever card
it's hard for people but that's what I
mean I think you've got to have faith
that and people will love you and accept
you I've never been able to hold down a
nine-to-five because I've not been able
to regulate my mood whilst in the
workplace obviously I've tried to remove
myself from the situation I don't let my
my moons get out of control I'll sort of
go outside and do what I need to do but
unfortunately I think there is still a
stigma in that in the workplace when I
disclosed my condition which is kinda
really new about it it was more that I
want to be the best worker that I can be
so I'm letting you know my issues we can
communicate openly just as we would do
if I told you that I had arthritis and
money if I don't think my medication or
if I forget because I'm late I have to
go home job
that but that's the thing I think
sometimes they can think that you're not
bothered I think I've found employers
and colleagues of thought she doesn't
care about the job she's not she's not
turned up or one of the reasons that
I've been fired in the past is
emailing and sick instead of ringing in
sick that's because I cannot physically
pick up the phone one day it's just not
understood I think because it's not a
physical illness and you can't see it if
people think it's not real I imagine
something and I panic about it and like
you said in my bed shaking why are you
panicking I miss my friend over there
dying
personal not hurt like self-care is it's
difficult sometimes I'm like oh yeah
why am I not a boy well I just get a
trailer my pawns on out after shave us
I'm share and just come out of house you
can you can embrace I think you can
embrace those days and go you know what
I don't have to be perfect every day if
I'm having a day where I don't want to
make myself look pretty and I want to
you know look a bit like Mowgli
something called a I'm gonna embrace
that and I'm gonna sit and wallow in bed
and I'm gonna you know eat junk food and
watch Netflix and just go okay and no
don't beat yourself up about it you know
[Laughter]
that everything is temporary because I
think that's one thing that you can
really feel when you're in that mood if
you're in that low mood you feel like
it's gonna last forever you cannot see
any way out at times and you know that's
what saved me is knowing that it's not
permanent so yeah you're not alone in it
it's not gonna last forever figure out
how your brain works
figure out your triggers understand
those deeper parts of yourself so that
like you said this doesn't become
permanent you don't have to live stay in
this state there is medication there is
therapy which I will always advocate for
and go for go for walks go outside do
what you love embrace creativity when
you're in your high period
his self-care through our ups and down
because it will serve you when you're
down don't just do it in crisis